the eh-2-zed of isms Zionism for its
supporters Zionism is the national
liberation movement of the Jewish people
for its opponents it is a means to
establish a settler colonial state in a
developing world Theodor Herzl a
Viennese journalist and playwright
founded the modern Zionist movement in
1897 yet many Orthodox Jews strongly
opposed the rise of Zionism they believe
that the Jews would only return to Zion
the land promised by God to the Jews in
the Hebrew Bible with the eventual
coming of the Messiah Jews should
therefore not force God's hand there
were many types of Zionist marxist
religious nationalists liberal social
democrat the forerunners of today's
political parties in Israel but Zionism
and Arab nationalism arose during the
same period of history the claims over
the same piece of land geographical area
known for centuries to Jews as the land
of Israel this is the ideological basis
of the seemingly intractable
israel-palestinian conflict while
there's been a Jewish presence in the
Holy Land since biblical times at the
beginning of the 20th century the Jews
were few in number compared to Christian
and Muslim Arabs
unlike other national liberation
movements whose supporters were actually
living on the territory that they wished
to free Zionist Jews had first to
emigrate from a far-flung diaspora build
an infrastructure and only then initiate
a liberation struggle Zionism their form
does not fit into conventional theory so
is Zionism wrong or just different in
the aftermath of the French Revolution
many 19th century jews began to regard
themselves as a people with a history
literature culture and language and not
just followers of an ancient religion
Judaism many were highly influenced by
progressive national movements in Europe
such as the Risorgimento of Mazzini
Garibaldi for United Italy and Irish
Republican efforts to throw off the yoke
of British domination the example of
Russian revolutionary Lenin influenced
the social scientist leader and first
Prime Minister of Israel David
ben-gurion Lenin demonstrated what could
be achieved with a handful of supporters
many issue or peon Jews wanted to escape
the heavy hand of Russian anti-semitism
the early Zionists were often
revolutionary socialists who not only
wished to build a new country but also
to construct a new society unlike the
ones they had just left one of the
building blocks of this new society was
the kibbutz a self-sufficient
self-governing collective there were
many possible territorial solutions
where a Jewish state could be built they
range from the Portuguese colony of
Angola to the Jewish autonomous region
in the USSR that would be John on the
border of China Herzl even approached
the British with the idea that Uganda
might be a night shelter on the road to
the Land of Israel some supporters
believe that Zionism completed its tasks
when the State of Israel was established
in 1948 others believe that the Zionist
project cannot be considered complete
until Israel is at peace secure within
its boundaries and within the wider
region and creates a fairer society for
all its inhabitants
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon